han pasado casi dos meses Desde que la
comisión europea propusiera este nuevo
paquete de sanciones se trata de la
undécima ronda muy centrada sobre todo
en evitar que Rusia pueda eludir las
sanciones para empezar se va a prohibir
el tránsito de bienes y de tecnologías
dentro de territorio ruso que luego se
puede utilizar en el ámbito militar
también se va a prohibir la venta y
exportación de ciertos productos a
terceros países si Estos son sospechosos
de que estos productos luego vayan a
parar a Rusia no hay una lista de países
pero sí que se va a estudiar
detenidamente si existe esta posibilidad
de que estos productos luego vayan a
parar a este país esto había sido una de
las cuestiones que más había preocupado
durante las negociaciones entre los
países europeos ya que temían que esto
pudiera afectar en las relaciones
bilaterales por ejemplo con china
tampoco se permitirá la entrada de
buques y barcos que sean sospechosos
también de eludir las restricciones y
las sanciones que existen actualmente
frente al petróleo ruso en territorio
europeo las sanciones esperan que ahora
mismo puedan entrar en los próximos días
en vigor la presidenta de la comisión
europea uso la fonter Legend asegura que
este nuevo paquete de sanciones es un
nuevo golpe contra la maquinaria bélica
de Rusia